I arrived in England at the height of
brexit mania the tourists were happy
because the entire country had gone on
sale some of the locals were morose then
some of them just didn't care
like the people drinking these $20
cocktails at a fancy hotel bar
nothing says hello to financial ruin
like sipping rum from an elephant made
of Legos or gin from whatever this is
you know who else doesn't care about
brexit people willing to pay $400 for a
hair dryer
Dyson as we all know has perfected suck
now it's on to blow meet the supersonic
according to the ample Dyson propaganda
this is the smartest hair dryer ever
built it uses an electric digital motor
to produce an intense stream of air and
then sensors to make sure that air never
gets too hot
as a result your hair comes out shinier
and healthier than ever before I feel
like I'm two inches taller down to see
how Dyson built this thing I had to
leave London and head to the company's
headquarters in the picturesque town of
Malmesbury James Dyson founded this
company in 1991 and has created his very
own engineering paradise the Dyson
campus is littered with his toys of
course you have a plane in the cafeteria
and made up of a handful of invention
factories my first stop is with someone
who leads a constant battle to come up
with ideas for brand new products and
reinvent some old ones
hairdressers haven't changed it sort of
60 years if we look at this this cutaway
here you see they've got a very large
motor inside like that but that weight
you're holding you know for 20 minutes
half now where you're drying your hair
and very very noisy so we thought it's a
really good product for us to get into
dyson spent four years and 71 million
dollars to bring the supersonic to life
and as you might expect they're
obsessive-compulsive when it comes to
hair
we felt that we had to learn everything
about hair the science of hair we had to
put our own laboratory to learn about
hair for ourselves and then what causes
damage what causes shine what makes your
hair look lovely hi welcome to lap 61
I'd you very much ask you to put a lap
go home because this place is gonna be
kept spotless
Matthew child is Dyson's electric motor
wizard he spent more than a decade
developing the core of so many Dyson
products the vacuums have big motors and
the hairdryer has this tiny thing
a miniature turbine this is more tuned
to a jet engine you find on commercial
airliner than anything else how fast
does it spin around 115 thousand rpm so
that's about 18 hundred revolutions
every second yeah it seems almost
impossible it's possible through very
fast electronics and a mechanical system
that is able to take the stresses the
strains for hundreds of hours at full
speed the electric motor technology will
be key to Dyson's continued push into
new product areas some people say it's
secretly working on an electric car what
types of things would this be useful at
the moment we applied it to the air dry
the way and see what comes next
I knew you would say that can only say
that